- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape;
bipedal, naked large-brained. Lone the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Maria] I was very ambitious when I
decided this title. And it's not going to
be covered all of it in 20 minutes for
sure. But I'll try to cover as much as
possible and give you an idea of what we
know about the genetic history of the
Americas, mostly informed by ancient DNA
studies. So the last continent to be...the
Americas was the last continent to be
settled by humans and many questions have
been debated as to where did the first
people to enter the Americas came from,
when did they come to the Americas,
through what route, and if there was one
major or two major or three major
migrations into the Americas. So there has
been a lot of debate and attempts to
answer these questions. And many fields
have contributed to the discussion and
genetics has been very important, but it
has received contributions as well from
linguistics, archeology,
paleo-anthropology, paleo-climate and
other disciplines. And it is now kind of
agreed that the first people to enter the
continent did so from Siberia, Northeast
Asia, through Beringia around 15,000 years
ago. And we set that date because the
oldest human occupation site in the
Americas is Monte Verde which is here in
Chile. And this human occupation site is
dated to 14,000 to 14,500 years old. So
the people who first entered the continent
had to do so before then and like allowing
of time for people to get here. So ancient
DNA has contributed a lot to understanding
exactly how this happened, how people
moved through the continent and where did
they come from. And we don't have
thousands or hundreds of ancient genomes,
we have only a handful from the Americas.
So I will try to give you some of the
insights that we've gained from studying
ancient Native American genomes. So the
first one is this genome from the Anzick
boy, which where some remains found here
in Montana and where they dated to around
12,600 years old. And they were found in
association with these fluted stone spear
points which were part of the Clovis
culture. And as far as I know, these are
the only remains that have been found in
association to these tools. So this
allowed the opportunity to investigate,
like, the genetic affinities of a Clovis
culture by studying the genome. When the
genome was sequenced and compared to human
populations around the globe, like
contemporary populations around the globe,
this heat map, flash map was generated
which basically shows in warmer colors the
population, each circle is a population.
So in warmer colors, you have the
populations that have the highest genetic
history sharing. So, the first thing that
was observed by sequencing this 12,000
year old individual was that most Native
Americans, basically all Native Americans
are more similar to this individual than
any other population in the world. And
most interestingly, it was found that even
though it was found like in the northern
part of the Americas, it was more closely
related or have more genetic affinity to
Central and South American contemporary
individuals, Native Americans actually.
And this already gave us an idea about
kind of the structure that was occurring
in the Americas back then. And together
with these observations and other
statistical analyses, the authors of these
study which I should mention Morten
Rasmussen who did this between Copenhagen
and Stanford. Well, they came up with this
model in which there was a divergence
predating the 12,000 years old of this
ancient genome. A divergence between the
Northern Native Americans and the Southern
Native Americans. And that Anzick would be
sitting here.
So, this genome was very insightful in
that it gave us an idea of some early
population structure in the Americas
predating the age of this genome. And it
also gave us the idea that most Native
Americans today are descendant of a
population related to this
Clovis-associated genome. A second genome
that was sequenced just recently and
published recently and the source of a lot
of debate was that of the Kennewick Man.
The remains of this individual were found
in the Kennewick area in Washington state.
And they were dated to 8,500 years. And
there was... Again, this is a study by
Morten Rasmussen. This was a source of a
lot of controversy because the first
analysis on the skeletal remains and
particularly on the morphology of the
skull. So the scientists who did this
first analysis they said that the
morphology of the skull was more similar
to contemporary individuals of Southeast
Asia and Polynesians. So, what that led to
was the owners of the land, which was
actually the US Army, not giving the
remains to the Native American tribes who
were claiming these remains for reburial.
And that was just based on the scientist
who drew these conclusions on the
morphology of the skull alone. So of
course, there was a lot of scientific
debate. And because the first attempts to
extract DNA were unsuccessful, there was a
lot of controversy and litigation for many
years, at least nine years. But finally
this group in Copenhagen, they're very
good at this, were given the opportunity
to try again to do some genetic analysis.
And they were able to sequence an entire
genome of the Kennewick Man. So the very
first observation is that it actually
falls within Native American variation,
just like that. And so this is a BCA plot
similar to what Johannes just showed. And
these are contemporary Native Americans,
these are populations from the rest of the
world, this is Europe. So, that was the
first result, this individual is Native
American. And when looking at the genetic
affinities within America, it was shown
something similar to what was shown for
the Anzick individual. It shares more
genetic history with Central, North and
South Americans than with other Native
Americans from the North, even though it
was found here. But it was also
interesting to find that tribes for the
same area where the Kennewick Man was
found, also shared a high level of genetic
ancestry with the Kennewick Man. So this
was like another piece of evidence about
the past genetic structure in the
Americas. So again, with this observation
and more sophisticated statistical
methods, what this study proposed was
that, so this was the original branching
between Northern Native Americans and
Southern Native Americans. The Anzick sits
here as an ancestor to modern South and
Central Native Americans. But there was
another branching here, and Kennewick is
here, that gave rise to Pacific Northwest
Native Americans. But there was a follow
by some gene flow from East Asia that
probably obscures a little bit the genetic
affinity of the Kennewick to the Pacific
Northwest Native Americans. So this was a
very important contribution and not only
gave us insights about the past genetic
structure of the Americas, but it also
helped resolve this controversy about
whether Kennewick Man was Native American
or not.
And now, just an additional report
supporting this was published three days
ago, probably. So we could hopefully put
an end to this litigation and these
remains...well, we don't know because many
tribes are claiming the remains so maybe
there will be yet another debate. But
anyway, this is what we learned from the
scientific standpoint. And the third
genome I will tell you about is this from
the Saqqaq Paleo-Eskimo, which is very
interesting because it was sequenced from
a tuft of hair and this hair was preserved
for around 4,000 years in the present
permafrost in Southwest Greenland. And
this is an artistic reconstruction of the
individual based on genotype, like
phenotypic information that was taken from
the genome that was sequenced. So this was
actually the first ancient human genome to
be sequenced and again, this was done in
Copenhagen by Morten Rasmussen and
colleagues. So what we learned about this
genome was also very interesting. So the
Saqqaq individual was found here but the
genetic affinity surprisingly, or not to
some, are not to modern contemporary
Greenlanders. So this individual is
genetically more similar to individuals
from Siberia like Chukchi and Koryaks
here. So what this indicated is that there
was probably a past migration like
predating 4,000 years ago, probably 5,000
to 6,000 years, a migration from Northeast
Asia to the Americas that was later
replaced by a population that gave rise to
modern day Inuits. So these are, like,
three single genome studies, but thanks to
the development in next generation
sequencing we have been able to generate
now multi- or... Well, yes, complete or
semi-complete genomes from different
individuals more than just one at a time.
So we generated some genomic data from
multiple individuals to test one
particular hypothesis.
This was part of a larger study but my
contribution was testing this
Paleo-American relics hypothesis. So,
again, based on this morphology of the
skull, it was suggested that the very
first people to enter the Americas and for
which we have remains like for example,
Lucia from Lagoa Santa and the Penan woman
which are really, really old, that the
morphology of this skull is more similar
to present day people from Melanesia. Some
scientists suggest that there was a first
migration of people with this
Paleo-American skull that was later
replaced completely by Siberia, like the
first migration I mentioned. And that
there was a complete wipeout and
replacement. But that there were some
relic populations because based on the
morphology of the skull of some
individuals who are in isolated parts of
the continent like the Pericos in the tip
of Baja, California and the
Fuego-Patagonians here, these had a
particular skull morphology that resembles
also Austra-Melanesians. So this was a
theory and we wanted to test it. So we
sequenced partial genomes from 17
individuals from these supposedly relict
populations. And what we found, we were
actually expecting this already, was that
they all fall within Native American
variations, so there was no evidence of
any connection to Austra-Melanesia
whatsoever. But more interestingly is that
we observe a genetic continuity with
modern populations in the same geographic
area. For example, the people from
Fuego-Patagonia in PCA space, they fall in
proximity to present day Fuego-Patagonians
from Chile, so the [inaudible 00:13:46]
from Chile. And similar in Mexico. The
Pericos from Mexico not only fell within
the native variation in Mexico, but they
did so with Northern population from
Mexico. So we were able to pin down that
they were very closely similar to
Tarahumara and Purépecha which are
Northern Native groups in Mexico. Well,
first we just disprove this idea of relict
Paleo-Americans. And secondly we
demonstrated that there is this genetic
continuity. And actually we observed this
in many samples now, in many genomes that
have been sequenced. And we observed so,
as I showed a little bit with the
Kennewick Man that had genetic affinity to
populations from the same geographic area.
But we've observed through almost 8,000
years so we have different genomes from
different ages here. And what we've
observed continuously is that there seems
to be this genetic continuity in the
Americas, and that is in contrast with
what Johannes just showed ofthese massive
demographic shifts. So the Americas, at
least Central and South America, the
Northern part seems to be a bit more
complex, but at least Central and South
have been kind of very stable for many
thousands of years, so that's interesting.
A question that hasn't been resolved quite
yet is if there were three or two
migration waves into the Americas.
Different groups with different data sets
from modern populations support one or the
other. So there is one model that...there
was one major migration that gave rise to
most Native Americans followed by a second
and a third that were mostly just Northern
Native Americans. And there is another
model that instead of suggesting a second
migration, suggests that there was
divergence within America of a Northern
and a Southern branch and that this
occurred within America approximately
13,000 years ago. And something that has
been a bit puzzling for us who study
genetic diversity in the Americas is the
observation by two independent studies of
something that looks like gene flow from
Austra-Melanesians or Papua, New
Guinians, or population related to
contemporary Papua, New Guinians and
Melanesians, into populations in the
Amazonian, like the Xavante, Suruí and
Karitiana. And two independent studies
have identified this signal, although yet
we don't have a good explanation of how or
when this happened. So it's very puzzling
actually. And just for the last part, I
want to make the point that so far I just
talked about the peopling of the Americas,
but there's actually much more genetic
history in the recent 15,000 years of
course. So I think we can use ancient DNA
to investigate, or a combination of
ancient and modern DNA, to investigate
other regional aspects of the history of
the Americas. An example here, for example
is the peopling of the Caribbean. By it's
location you can argue it could have been
people from Florida, from the Yucatan
peninsula or from South America. And now
combining data from modern population,
modern Caribbean population and studying
the Native American fraction of this
population and comparing to a reference
panel of Native Americans, it has been
suggested that it was people, actually, by
South America here, facilitated by the
Orinoco River. And we have been able to
kind of prove this with ancient genomes
from Taino genomes. And I'm just showing
here an example of one sample from Cuba,
from Chorro de Maita, Cuba which also
falls in the genetic variation of Arawakan
speakers, like Wahiro, Piapoco and Ticuna.
So this is another way we're complimenting
information from modern and ancient
population to resolve a question about the
particular event in history. And I'm also
doing something on the same lines. I don't
have the time to tell you more about it,
but we're doing something similar in the
peopling of the Patagonia, like the very
last part that was peopled in the
Americas.
And lastly, I want to make the point that
we can also use ancient DNA even in
historical times, but for events in
history where the historical record is
sparse. So, I'll just show you an example
where we used ancient DNA to learn about
the past history of people brought to the
Americas as a result of the Trans-Atlantic
Slave Trade. You can argue that there is
historical records about this, but this
exact origins of people in Africa that
were brought to the Americas that was
basically not recorded, it's kind of
absent in the historical record. So we can
also use ancient DNA to reconstruct some
of this history. So in this, very quickly,
it was a pilot study where we had three
individuals from the Caribbean and we
wanted to know where in Africa were they
from. They were found in the same burial
site. And by comparing to a reference
panel in Africa, we sequenced fractions of
their genomes, we were able to find that
one of them was more closely related to
Bantu-speaking populations. And two of
them were more closely related to
non-Bantu-speaking populations and we had
evidence to argue that this three people
were put in the same embarkation and
brought to the Americas together. But we
are really missing information about how
culturally diverse were the people who
were brought from Africa to the Americas.
So, just to summarize, most Native
Americans...because I went through
something very general like the peopling
of the Americas to something super
specific about an episode in history. But
I want you to take this messages home. So
most Native Americans trace their ancestry
to a single migration from East Asia to
Beringia between 15,000 and 20,000 years
ago. If there was one, two or three
subsequent migration is still under
debate. There is evidence of ancient gene
flow from population related to
Austra-Melanesians in some Amazonian
populations, although we don't know
exactly how that happened. The sequencing
of ancient genomes from the Americas has
complimented the knowledge generated from
studying genome-wide data from modern
populations. But we still have very few
compared to Europe, for example. And this
last point, it's also something very
important for me, ancient DNA research can
also be useful for investigating other
aspects apart from the initial peopling of
the continent. I think we put too much
attention into that that we've forgotten
about the more recent history or
pre-history, like the source populations
in Africa of the people who were brought
during the Trans-Atlantic Slave Trade. And
with that I'll complete, and thank you.
♪ [music] ♪